miss Bea shared some pictures never
shared with anybody and honestly I was
really shocked I didn't even know I'd
even know how to react and I have
witnessed a lot of things as a coach I
have experienced hundreds of stories and
I have to tell you this was the most
unique of them all it's on me
if they don't dig deep and get to the
truth it's my fault
[Music]
so the original exercise was to go
through their foundation story because
every single entrepreneur that starts a
business that matters it needs to come
from a place of purpose and that purpose
comes from pain but what I did not
expect at all was was the confessions
that came out changing my life I decided
consciously to turn back the hands of
time but I one out of everybody is just
to get to the truth because the truth is
where your beauty lies that's a reason
why you do the things that you do as
silly as it it is it was a big deal I
mean it still is a big deal like I don't
want to post nothing online saying oats
virus it's like even when I got featured
in a magazine one time the lady was like
oh how old are you and I hesitated in
her life and she's like you know why I'm
like like that's not who I am like I
don't want to and I can't even remember
honestly I can't remember if I told her
to right or wrong eight but most likely
Kankuro me has really brought the group
together
and it's so interesting because one of
the people said that we feel like family
the reality is we only spent a few hours
together and for them to really feel
like family and share the things that
they've never shared in front of the
real families like their biological
families is such an incredible honor
it's amazing it's amazing to see my
confession would be that I've always
been afraid to fail like I'm always and
I don't think I talked about that or
have really maybe ever said that out
loud before but that I've always taken
like safer I've taken safer paths always
you know kept like option B and C
available and you know I just I've not
been I've not been true to myself and
that like all you know be you and and be
be you and be all in fail like just fail
over you know first attempt in learning
FAI oh right
and I just I've cheated myself I think
along the way of my life because I've
taken the safer Pat's and Here I am talk
about age I'm 41 and you know I've got a
daughter it's gonna be going to college
hopefully if the Lord's will and she'll
be going off here in a couple years
and you know I'm while I'm happy about
where I'm at in life I feel like I could
have done so much more and I could have
been
so much more meaningful in other
people's lives and had more impact on
people's live if I would have not been
so damn scared and not been so
protective my father left when I was 10
and became a Walt Disney World Imagineer
for Christ's sakes I mean if that didn't
if that wasn't my life's lesson to go
Mike shoot for the stars man I mean you
may strike an eagle but shoot for the
moon you know and I have regret and
that's that's a you know now that I'm
here I'm realizing that you know
becoming effective in this in this space
you have to set that truth free and you
have to really find out what your what
your true values are and your shortfalls
your shortcomings like do an audit of
that like what's inside of you what you
know what's working what's not working
and own those things you know just stand
up to him and own them and face them you
know and be willing to talk about that
so one of the things that I haven't
really shared with a lot of people it's
kind of an embarrassing one is is that
I'm so afraid to go on a date I am so
afraid after go on a date with a man
because I'm recently divorced and I
haven't I haven't been with anybody
since my husband we were together for 19
years so I know everyone's like oh
you're gonna be fine but but it's scary
it's scary to to go out there and I
don't even know how to act like I don't
even know where do you begin
I don't even know if I'm ready it's also
having a failed marriage it's a scary
thing
having something that
[Music]
having a failed marriage almost seems
like it's a clash of my values because I
believe that it was supposed to be in a
long term thing was supposed to be for
the rest of my life but it ended so
yesterday was about knowledge dumping
trying to get as much information into
your heads as possible today is more
experience okay today we're gonna be
doing some fun work in front of the
camera both in front of a big camera
we're gonna be shooting bio videos we're
gonna have lights set up here we're
shouldn't one-on-one videos I'm gonna be
coaching you through it
alex is gonna be taking you through how
to do live stories as well as Instagram
snapchat stories be able to do that and
so coaching you outside on doing it
little is gonna be work with you on
doing the foundation story jurors gonna
be working you on design any ideas
suggestions you have things you want him
to look at we're going to push you to do
stuff that might be outside your comfort
zone trust the process I know some of
you guys yesterday already felt a little
stretched from some of the exercises and
the conversations both in studio and at
dinner last night he was what I would
ask you to do this is a safe place we've
already shared some vulnerable things
together Alex Jay Rhys Lilly myself
everybody here we're not judging you for
any of your paths or secrets or darkness
I'd encourage you to try to be as open
and vulnerable as possible whether you
want to end up using the video or not
it's up to you but encourage you to get
the practice of being vulnerable on
sharing on camera okay you sign up here
for a reason so we're gonna push you
accept the push and hopefully you're
able to take some of that home to go off
on me thought leaders and change the
world what I want you to try to do in
channeling content today whether you're
doing your design work whether you're
doing your on-camera snapshots towards
any of that stuff I want you to not just
tell the story get the information out
but I want you to try to channel the
emotion alex has a special announcement
are you serious hi I'm Jay Rhys and I
help Evan build his empire we're gonna
get everyone together analyze their
content and improve the design well
ideally a logo you have two options the
same thing with a name
you either leverage this power and love
which is something that exists there's
power in leveraging symbols right so if
I have an airplane it's taking off right
that means something to you because you
know what an airplane is where I know
what taking off is and you can relate to
it when we have a sonic boom happening
it's meant to be powerful right right so
I'm leveraging something like why do
people want to in the US election why do
they always wear like the US flag and
with like as a pin it's and but it's
because people already know what that is
and so they think oh that's presidential
right so the power be used in an
existing symbol is that you get to
leverage all of the brand association
that's already tied to that symbol right
right so if you have an airplane people
associate things with an airplane right
you get to steal all of the
associations people have it in their
plane for your own brand so it's a
shortcut to help people with it with
your logos with all your designs you
want people to feel something so we had
a lot of success Mike ended up changing
his name entirely because respond was
not the right fit miss B got clarity on
her logos and her business name and her
word mark Tamara we had some intense
discussions I think she has a lot of
food for thought which is good because
you can't rush design and and Doug ended
up helping the board members of another
company he's involved in she's helping
them with their logo I love it so I'm
working with the entrepreneurs right now
you have Mike Doug miss B and Tamara and
what I'm helping them walk through is
how to say their stories with emotion
that when they say something like I am
so happy right now they feel the
happiness it's not just saying where
it's like I'm excited but there's no
excitement I'm excited and learning to
filter that themselves so I had this
moment this beautiful moment with with
Mike or he was like thanking his wife
and I told her I'm like if she watched
that is she gonna feel that you're so
grateful that she let you go off for an
extra eight days not to see your kids to
be able to do growth and I saw him get
teary-eyed and emotion I'm like
this is what they need to see because I
think always that authenticity will
always trump the words you might have
the best words you can figure those out
but if you're authentic you let other
people feel vulnerable around you and if
I'm an Argentine and I'm watching
someone in San Francisco even if we
don't live in the same life I can feel
the love with Doug Doug here loves his
life as well
and he he wants to show his wife in the
world how much he loves her and how
significant and important this is with
Tamara she felt that she's finally part
of a tribe that she belongs she got
really really emotional so I'm helping
her bring that out from yesterday's
event with MS B she had only her brother
out of her whole family that rallied for
her and fought for her to give her
freedom and to believe in her and I'm
helping her bring out that that love for
her brother Dennis Dennis you're a rock
star you sending this message to Dennis
right yeah
what Saul we're gonna also share on your
story though yeah send Oh where's Dennis
something was wrong so they were being
done
man like they're finally getting in
touch with themselves and and they're
realizing that any emotion can be coming
from a place of strength and can be an
inspiration and ultimately it's not the
story that they say right now but it's
the skills that they're gonna take and
inspire others in their industries
they're all superstars and I'm grateful
that I've been part of it
[Music]
all right smokers what do we got over
here who's next who's next
done thank you French Dougie fresh
in the house here we go still work all
right go baby
good luck obviously using the FBI
treatment Egeria the air conditioning
going so you want to see some sweat and
stuff like that the standard template
intro has been just what we want to it
Lily I'm gonna run oh my go
yeah good call so hi I'm Doug and I am
whatever okay
hi I'm Doug and I'm you know what you
said what do you first line is yes okay
what's your first line hi I'm Doug and
I'm I absorbed water yeah a paramedic
yeah okay and then like what and I
believe what what's your next line well
kind of what I was gonna do is just you
know they were talking about a little
bit of a story of the you know like the
pain and stuff like before that and like
a align to intro everything okay I'm
here to talk about entrepreneurism oh
okay my story about entrepreneurialism
goes back to my mother
my mother had a small business that did
not work and failed and I I got to
experience the ugly side of
entrepreneurial the crash
and and wondered what that did to me was
a clinically true choose a profession
that was exciting but yet safe but I've
always had this entrepreneurial ISM
thing in the back of my mind going
so
I'm a grand rear break family but now
I'm at the tail end of my career and
it's time to transition so now the
exciting time of my life has come I get
to live my dream of trying to become an
entrepreneur or make something happen
not the opportunity to invest in venture
capital I've had the opportunity to take
self-help classes I've had the
opportunity to get involved and the
pension world which has exposed me to a
tremendous amount of money managers and
just the ability of not having regrets I
don't know where I'm going to land but I
do know this guy is not gonna have
regrets I'm taking my shot and you know
what I don't care I'm going for it so my
message to you is don't miss your shot
but if you if you think you mentioned
your shot there's still time to take a
shot so for those of you that want to
follow me whether I crash and burn it
doesn't matter because I've already won
I've taken a step I'm not gonna have any
regrets you can follow me on Twitter
Instagram and my future YouTube channel
and I hope you pay
don't live like with regrets take your
step you can make it happen
so day two of my workshop is in the
books and it's funny because people
thought they were coming to learn about
YouTube tips and strategies and how to
rank with their videos and analytics and
all that and we touched on some of those
things but the most important part if
you want to win and be a thought leader
an expert is you have to share yourself
and a lot of the work that we end up
doing that you guys saw here on the vlog
is touching into the vulnerable side if
you want to be a leader if you want to
win a lot of times people just think you
have to be perfect you're afraid to show
the weakness but people don't respect
the people who are always perfect people
look up to someone who's perfect and
says that person doesn't get me and so
you don't listen to that person's advice
because they're in a different planet
they're - they're too perfect they're
not human yeah yeah okay get a lose
there it is I'm so showing the chinks in
your armor showing the vulnerability
showing that you're a human being too
when showing the problems that you went
through is an inspiration to the people
who can learn from you and so before
people will ever listen to you about
your opinion on anything you have to
show them that you understand the
situation they are coming from
[Music]
and that comes by sharing a personal
vulnerable story and the more you do
that the more you can influence people
and the more you're gonna win
[Music]
see love you it's like that's day 2 in
the books thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever you're one where it is
much love I'll see you soon if you tell
yourself a story long enough you start
to believe it won't you believe it you
act like I have Tulsa what a wail out of
handcuffed lightning though Thunder in
jail now you know I'm bad over the last
week I've murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick the fundamental key to
success is it can take between eighteen
and two hundred and fifty four days of
taking action for a new habit to stick
I've created a new course called 250 for
confidence or every single day for 250
four days I will be sending you a video
between 30 seconds and 5 minutes long
that you start your morning with around
making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access